um a few of our newer comics who just
got into this
struggle with that idea of what do i
write about my life nothing about my
life is funny but so what do i write
about
and earlier earlier you referenced to um
one of your students you gave him 50
questions not
going through all 50 of them but what
are like maybe like five ideas that they
could
questions they could answer to
themselves ask themselves if that
could get them started with writing yeah
that's a great one it's like um
um what what is your ill relationship
status
because it's primal right those are the
things that we deal with we deal with
things that are primal sex procreation
survival
money uh struggle with money shelter
food
um i like to talk about things that that
actually prompt the brain to produce
serotonin
like uh the food network has figured it
out right they just show you this food
and they're like and plus they gamified
it and added the competition with a
countdown clock what the what the
else can they do to create drama
right and we're like and we see the food
in our mouth waters and our brains are
releasing this serotonin and we're like
oh man i gotta
let's watch the food network again you
know i eat i cook so much more now since
watching that
those shows but what what you can do
is like you you know that's another
subject we can talk about that's the
food network it's an experience i have
and people can relate to that because
it's all of that's relatable a lot of
people go to porn because there's shock
value there
i would i would take what everybody else
is doing and go the other direction
you know it's okay to drop something in
one time as a reference
you know uh it's like oh somebody's been
watching a lot of porn if it's in the
moment
that's fine but don't i would go you
know you see everyone
smoking weed you know you can just
pretty much rattle off what everybody's
talking about
go the other direction uh and find the
nuances
in life and those little things and it's
like when joel
uh gives you that one word is maybe
something you
would have never written on before but
now you're forced
to so it's like what are people talking
about let me go to some of this minutia
in life
that is people see it but they don't
talk about it yeah like you ever watch
somebody wait for the bus
and you sort of step out now where's the
incongruity where's the
paradox where's the irony in that them
waiting for the bus they wait on the bus
they're on the curb that's seven inches
high
they look for a bus that's 16 feet tall
i know i've measured
uh and they're waiting for the bus they
don't see the ball so they step down
off the curb into the street losing
seven inches
then they raise up a couple of inches
lost a total of five inches of
perspective if you can't see the bus
from up there you're not gonna be able
to see it from down there
so now you have the irony of stepping up
the curb to look for the bus
built into that story and you know
people laugh at the irony also
that's silly why would he do that
superiority we feel superior to that
person
and so that'll get the audience and uh
you know recognition observation and
coincidence oh my god i see that all the
time how come i never thought about it
that way
so those little nuances sometimes
produce
the material but then you say how can i
put it what so what will make it funny
irony will make it funny hypocrisy will
make it funny because
usually irony is uh usually hypocrisy
contains some level of irony
paradox will make it funny um
incongruity
you know what make it funny uh if you
have a reverse shadow an assumption that
would make it funny
um you know it's like you know you're
talking about the person waiting for the
bus
it's like you know then they go out in
the street they raise up on their toes
which is weird because they're
in a wheelchair um that could make it
funny um
and then you could so you see what i'm
saying there's like
if you know these if you know the
techniques which come from practicing
those one and two liners even if that's
not your thing man
my thing when i'm up on stage is not one
and two liners
i'm doing stories i'm doing experiences
i'm talking about
you know things that happened to me and
how i encountered an obstacle on my way
to a goal i'm not like uh
you know two guys walk into a bar but
it's writing those one and two liners
that get me that proficiency to be able
to take just write a story
then come back through and go joke here
joke there joke there joke there okay
riff off on that go off in this
direction come back to the story
you know all of that now is possible
because i can see that
in the material because of the you know
there's 13 comedy structures to work
from
plus other you know cliche reformations
and analogies and
that are instant you know built-in tools
to
punch up us a script you know to punch
up a story
you know you need a look at bill burr
his whole act is driven through his
likes
is like as like as like as like his like
and all he's doing is putting these two
similar ideas together boom punching it
up hitting some imagery
moving on with his story with a very
strong emotional commitment to
his point of view which is you know it
made him uh
you know the famous bill bereas today
but he uses a lot of big
is like to get there but you got to keep
in mind bill burr
the first five to seven years of his
career he was doing one and two liners
because he had to know how to write a
joke and now when his stories it's
easier to get to that joke because of
that experience of writing jokes
even you know it's like your scales if
you're playing guitar playing piano you
don't know your scales
it's going to be really hard for you to
do studio work you know so
it's learning the fundamentals you know
as comics we want to get there so
quickly we want to get to the show and
we want to get
the you know people get up there but you
get a comic up there the moment they say
what else
i tune out what else what else what else
what else you didn't do your homework
bro you know that's what else
you know you gotta you gotta you gotta
do your homework i'm old school that way
it's like
if these guys are paying for these seats
i'd better be prepared to
bring them a show otherwise i'm
disrespecting them
you know and you're there to give them a
gift without them or nothing
if you're serious about becoming a
comedian join our facebook group linked
in the description below to start
getting tips like these every single day
and watch this playlist of our top
writing tips to improve your writing
[Music]
today